- [Interviewer] All right, so, Christie.
- Yeah?
- [Interviewer] What's been going on?
You look so much better
than I've ever seen you.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I've seen
you for almost a year now.
- [Christie] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Almost
every day, every other day.
And you look great.
- [Christie] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're
no longer in your tent.
- [Christie] No, I'm not in a tent.
- [Interviewer] Tell me what's going on.
- Well, I just, you know being in a tent,
you become too comfortable.
I had to step out of it.
I had to step out of the
tent and move forward,
step out of Skid Road, as you say.
And you know...
I don't know, oh God.
Well, it's not like I'm
any better from in a tent
but I'm in the process of getting housing,
I'm actually closer to
getting it than I think.
Well, that's what my caseworker said.
But I'm not letting
negative people get to me.
I'm still turning my dates,
but I'm doing it a little more classy.
(both chuckle)
- [Interviewer] You look classier so.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you're still using?
- I still get high,
but not like I used to.
- [Interviewer] So you're using less?
- I use a whole lot less.
That's great.
- Yeah.
I'm being honest, you know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What do you think has
caused these changes in you?
- Well, I took a look at myself.
Well, I mean, your-
- [Interviewer] My video?
- Yeah, took a look at myself and-
- [Interviewer] That's pretty harsh.
- Yeah, and like that's,
you know, that's not me.
This right here isn't even me.
I know what I used to
look like and everything,
and I know I can get back to that.
But step by step, I'm getting there.
- [Interviewer] You're still young.
- Yeah, I'm still young.
- [Interviewer] You said your daughter.
You sat down with your
daughter and watched the video?
- Yeah, I watched a video
with my daughter, and...
God.
It was like a reality check
for me, and just, you know.
Explaining things to my
daughter about my life,
and I wanted to tell her,
I didn't want her to just find out things.
But letting her know about my life,
and what I'm going through,
and my family, and her family.
Yeah, but I'm doing more positive,
and I'm thinking positive,
and I'm hanging out with different crowds.
And yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's great,
it's so refreshing to
hear stories like this,
'cause they're rare down here.
- [Christie] Yeah, they are.
- [Interviewer] You're going
in the right direction.
What do you think would help you further,
to take it to...
- [Christie] Well-
- [Interviewer] To getting away from here,
to getting off the-
- [Christie] Honestly, if they
would speed up the process
of getting me into housing,
or like to where I'm not in the streets,
you know what I'm saying?
I would throw everything to the curb,
you know what I'm saying?.
As long as I know that
I got like a for sure,
I can pay my rent, you
know what I'm sayin'?
I just need a stepping stool, that's it.
- [Interviewer] Just getting a roof
over your head that's yours-
- [Christie] You know, just
something to get me started,
like a stepping stool.
And then I can sit there
and continue it on myself.
You know what I'm saying?
I just need a little you know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Christie] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you'd
get a place here in Skid Row,
or somewhere else?
- [Christie] Somewhere else.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
just to get away from-
- [Christie] Yeah, Skid
Row's over, it's played out.
It's played out.
(Interviewer chuckles)
- [Interviewer] I think it was played out
before you got here.
- It sure was.
I'm just another face, you know?
Another face, another story.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
that's a horrible life.
- Yeah, but everyone has their story,
and no one's better, no one's less.
We all got our bruises and cuts and scars,
and our stories to tell about it.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Well that's
so refreshing to hear.
Thank you so much for coming
and talking about it, and-
- Thank you, your website actually,
it gives you an eye opener,
for real, it does.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's just stories
as raw as you can get.
- Yeah, and the thing is though,
is that it's the truth,
it is all the things
that we've gone through,
and it's things that people
don't take the time out
to ask or try to get to know,
they don't even know about these people,
you know what I'm saying?
That if they do things
that happen to people
that they would know the reasons why
they're going through the things
that they're going through,
so they would sit there and understand
that we're not just bums,
or we're not just drug addicts,
we're people that's going
through some issues, that have...
You don't know how to
cope with things, but...
Or some people that
don't have family anymore
that have no help, or
people that are just lost.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Well you looked transformed
from that last video, for sure.
- Yeah, that last video...
Well, a trick, I got into it with a trick,
and messed my face up
- [Interviewer] No, but even your speech,
the way you're dressed, the whole thing,
you look like-
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're turning a corner.
- Yeah, and that video was like,
you know I have my opinion
on it, but still...
Yeah.
I have, you know, my-
- [Interviewer] What do you
think would help you the most?
Housing?
- Housing would help me.
What about a program?
- Housing would help me the most, and-
- [Interviewer] What about
some kind of recovery program?
- A program, honestly, I
think a program is a crutch,
but yet other people may need programs,
but honestly I feel that if
a person is ready to stop,
they're gonna stop, you
know what I'm saying.
I don't like to lie to myself.
But also a program, it is a support.
Some people need support,
while I do, yeah...
Support, I guess, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What I heard
in your voice in previous talks
was a lot of self pity.
And that's what I'm not hearing today.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Like
today, you're talking about
like how to improve,
and how to make the steps towards that,
whereas in the past you were just saying,
"poor me, poor me, poor me."
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's a big change.
- Yeah, but I mean,
everyone gets to the point
where they're all like,
"poor me," you know what I'm saying?
But you gotta put your big girl panties on
and deal with shit.
(Interviewer chuckles)
For real (laughs).
- [Interviewer] All right, Christie.
Thank you so much for talking to us.
- Uh-huh, welcome.
It was great.